hi herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute ich sitze zusammen
mit es kehlen und wir mal wieder was
gekauft und zwar ein kleines spiel ja
nicht irgendwo egal das ist dieses
einspritz piste
die haben ein spiel gekauft ein roulette
nennt sich das ganze sei das lustige an
roulette denk dir gedacht zu hause was
wir spielen das lustige an roulette
schnapp dir und fordere dein glück
heraus wirst du es bist du raus er
funktioniert glaube ich so wir machen
das ganze mal auf die praktisch keine
bedienungsanleitung breit meint versteht
hier noch drauf drehscheibe seele und
klatsch ist die an den kopf hast du ein
volles erwischt bist du raus da seht ihr
es leute dass sie mit schreiben könnte
zusammenbau durch erwachsene
erforderlich irgendwas sind wieder ein
wenig tiefer keller erwachsene gehört
haben irgendwie hier das waren kannst
weil ich probiert zusammen zu wahren so
wie du mal das zusammenbauen angeblich
zusammen war nur durch den wachsenden
problem ist eben auch nicht zusammen was
soll man leichter wenn es lustig wenn
nicht dann auch so wir packen das jetzt
mal aus weil diese sind erwachsene so
dass weitere hat einen sketch das
wahllokal wegen diesen entertainment das
war endlich ruhe auf jeden fall jetzt
packen wir den eierkarton hier aus dem
auto aus und fliegt die erste heraus das
hat erwachsenen sonst nicht verstehe ich
schon und zwar ist einfach immer ein
ober- und ein unterteil kannst dir
zusammenpacken befüllt zeit davor mit
wasser ein paar und dann geht egal was
kann ich kurz mitspielen
ja ich denke schon also für zwei keine
erwachsenen ihr wahrzeichen zu locken
jeden fall mit aus afk
zieht euch keine panik aufkommen zehn
eier sind insgesamt in der verpassen
hier drinnen vielleicht habt ihr schon
gesehen aber das ist kein normales video
also wir spielen nicht um ekligen saft
übrigen saft trinken die leute denken
wir schnell weg wie gesagt leute dazu um
was es wirklich geht ich war an der
grenze im blick ein und habe diese 2
justin bieber tattoos zum abziehen
geholt und wir machen es ganz einfach so
der verlierer darf sich ein justin
bieber-fans ted aussuchen hat sie nun
mal ein gerade das hier sind die beiden
justin bieber tattoos und ja das wird
auf jeden fall spaß ich nie wieder soll
man erfüllen wird selber befinden drei
befüllt ihr befüllt immer ein ei weniger
als spieler mit spiel eins für
vergessene film zwar wir befüllen ein
paar mehr natürlich so leute es wird
jetzt durch gemäss wir haben drei von
zehn eiern gefüllt und hier ist jetzt
der eierkarton sieht ziemlich gut aus
muss man sagen kosten 15 euro so und
jetzt packen wir den spaß mal aus sehr
gut dass es zuerst will jetzt weniger
märkten weiter das ist richtig raus hier
habe ich jetzt die drehscheibe das
prinzip kennt der mann dreht und wird
sich entscheiden ob wir überspringen 1
einnehmen ist in zwei eier nehmen müssen
oder dem anderen einen in die stirn
dürfen ok ok legen sie los
als erstes eine eigene heißt du musst du
musst deinen augen zu augen zu nicht
schauen schauen vielleicht könnt ihr
sehen alle gleich aus und 321 o ja okay
war auf jeden fall ein sauberes hast du
bist jetzt dran mitdrehen ich habe so
das gefühl immer wenn ich solche spiele
spielen im video auf denken wir die sind
oft und macht für youtube-videos wer
kauft sich das einfach normal weiter du
bist dran oder leute sebastian gerade
weiter gedreht
das haben wir hier wir haben vereinen
was aber sollte immer das moment was
heißt verein legen einfach denn machen
oder merke ich was da merkt einmalerlag
julia was aber nicht aber nicht so in
die nase hauen
da müssen zwei weg von 10 262 unscharfe
aber drei schafe sind heiß wir haben
noch acht wo man merkt richtig dass da
welche das sind also voll macht sie
bitte zwei stücke und rasiere ich dich
willkommen und wir haben ein einziger
meine erste setzte sich zuerst muss das
hier können wir können die hände denn
abgesucht irgendeine aus für die nicht
helfen ich schaue einfach nicht hin da
ist einfach blind
[Musik]
da war richtig was drin hast dir ist
rein gemacht das waren 3 liter wasser in
eine mannheimer sebastian schauen wir
noch mal eins kassiert das heißt unter
den verbleibenden sieben stück finden
sich noch zwei kontaminiertes steak aber
nicht alle leute ich hab gerade erfahren
dass sebastian allergisch gegen wasser
ist das auf jeden fall leichter hätte
meine augen das geht nur besser bei
20.000 likes überlegen wollte ihn
sterben lassen oder nicht so ist eure
entscheidung
ich würde ja auch gar nicht reinreden
aber ich würde mich schon stehen
menschen sterben lassen würde so die
leute wieder abrücken
und pastor 2
vor den verbleibenden sieben kannst dir
erstmal schön zweier einhändiger das ist
gut das ist gut was gut fühlt sich
schwer an sich wäre ja leute wenn man
glück alter schwede das habt ihr echt
schwer vielleicht ich finde also die
haben es ganz gut hinbekommen dass man
nicht sofort merkt dass der wind die
sind auch so schon ein bisschen schwer
ist also richtig dickes gummi hier als
ob schon wieder nichts
er würzt das kreuz drauf gemacht auf die
dinge ohne wasser herr jesus war darüber
macht man keine witze gleich die kurz
darauf ausgepackt gesicht schießen
spielte nicht doch machen nicht lange
das ist auch gar nicht dagegen die
spielregeln also doch kein werk für
seine heilung war meine augen zweier
zweier bücher die wahrscheinlichkeit ist
jetzt bei 40 prozent habe ich gerade
kurz ausgerechnet das dann noch ein ei
wasser erwischt wird okay abgibt zwei
stück wobei wahrscheinlich noch höher
weil es hätte wahrscheinlich gar zweimal
ziehen aber das wahrscheinlich leute
rechnet die wahrscheinlichkeit
mindestens ein einzuziehen wenn man
jetzt den rost kommen
okay wer das macht kriegt bei mir ein
herz ok ab jetzt ist ihr den kopf hin zu
den kommentaren herz claudia abgezockt
mit großen schmerzen wie viele mit
wasser noch drin
22 ich habe bisher das einzige gezogen
mir macht es einfach
ich schlage dir mein gesicht oder scannt
das kann gut aber ich habe ihn gestört
ich will ja nicht sagen leute aber
glaubt ihr ich mache nur ein video damit
glaubt ihr ich kauf mir nicht schleim
und bevor die eier mit schleim
zitronensaft dass die augen
vergessenheit und rast glaubst du ich
mache gefühl da würde ich sagen nein
aber was ich mag leute wenn ihr bock
drauf habt ja aber nur wenn ihr bock
drauf habt mache ich noch ein video wo
ich das mittägliche zeug befüllen
irgendwie mit teller marmelade oder
sonstwie und dann ballern wir uns die
dinger am kopf dann wird es richtig los
wir können ja zum beispiel sagen wir 55
stück mit wasser weil deines wasser
harmlos und die anderen sind mit nutella
und kot und so weiter auf du fängst du
ganz normal einsatz und am ende rettet
er immer wieder irgendwas scheint okay 1
muss noch ziehen es gibt ja okay okay
das war ein preis man leute bitte ok
gegeben
wir müssen hier durch schon voller und
bloss zwei stück kassierte kriegst ein
fester job verloren
du hast verloren aber kommen wir machen
jetzt ehren durchlauf ist ich mache
jetzt an sage ja ich jetzt mal auf das
spiel
ich nehme zwei stück raus und unter
diesen zwei stück wird nicht das letzte
sein dann muss denn das andere noch
zeigen ja ok jetzt ist die chance 50 50
dass ich das volle erwische mund zu voll
genommen ich hätte es eigentlich nicht
fressen müssen habe ich aber und jetzt
geht der spaß erst richtig los leute das
was von diesem video last gern erhalten
da muss mal warum mache ich so einen
scheiß mit dem haus ist dass du bist du
am a stehen dann muss was wären ein
guter punkt ich hab hier so'n neben dem
auge oder in seinem gesicht nation er
das ist ich würde sagen hier ist ein
guter punkt um das anzubringen das
tattoo weil das sieht authentisch aus
das ist lieblich das hat sich einfach
rauslassen gereinigt junger mann ich
habe heute abend noch ohne willen zu
fahren egal jetzt war ohne wird es wohl
was ich kann doch nicht so dahin geht
die haben mit einem einsatz gespielt ich
bei denen ich bekomme jetzt endlich auch
reger ich lasse nicht viel zu
leichtsinnig hab so was ein ich glaube
so auch lustig so dazu und dann bekommen
ist einfach da habe ich dann heute
verkauft ist seine schuld und es sah
jetzt drücken wir es ein bisschen an
nicht zu fest so nicht dass hier
irgendwie noch wasser raus läuft auf
keinen fall auch nicht dass mit waffen
fast also mit einem kran dort haben wir
auf jeden fall vermeiden
und jetzt ziehen wir es langsam ab wow
belieber warst du hast ein belieber
gesichts dazu für die nächsten sagen wir
mal 48 stunden wahrscheinlich bis ins
mittelalter aber unschön aber aber
zumindest mal privat jemanden bildschirm
jahres kids das ist richtig schlimm
hätte aber hat spaß gemacht mitzumachen
oder fast drei sekunden zu können so
leute bevor ich jetzt getötet werde hier
findet ihr ein altes video von mir für
euch vorgeschlagen hier unten könnt ihr
einen kanal abonnieren und dann würde
ich sagen ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
ich glaube ich werde jetzt angegriffen
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ist